♪
For me, I got to get my poop,
so to speak, in a square.
Tighten it up so that I'm
super Sue again.
But how do I do that?
These are the two
overflow tents,
and I'm not gonna have people
using them for quite a while.
So I want to annex this one
and make it into my physical
improvement center, the gym.
I don't have a big weight set
and a barbell
and you know, urgh,
things to lay down on.
And that's, that's not
the kind of improvement,
physical improvement,
I'm looking for.
What I'm trying to do is,
as I age,
the arthritis is setting in.
The range of motion
is decreasing.
The bears stay just as damn fast
as the moment they were born.
And I can't compete unless I
improve slightly where I'm at.
♪
I'm not looking to be
Susie Schwarzenegger.
I'm not the Sue-minator.
I'm flexi-Sue.
What I'm looking for is weight,
not heavy weight.
Light weights to work
my range of motion.
A cone on the runway
got in my way,
and I went down
like a little infant
not getting the candy bar.
I can't have fracturing going on
and instability
and expect to have
a top-notch-running place.
So I got some rope here,
got some pulleys here.
My body is hurting.
The pain that this shoulder,
whatever, is putting me through,
it's one more thing
in this cacophony of things
that's just riotously
making me break down.
I've got to do
my own form of therapy.
♪
It's time to get myself together
and, uh, maybe see
what I want to construct.
I'm approaching 60,
at 60 miles an hour.
I don't have angst
about getting older, per se,
but I can tell you, a body,
it's not regenerating anymore.
You're on the downhill cycle.
We are all gonna have
that epiphany that says
you now officially have lived
more years than you
are going to live.
Maybe everybody else's
road to health
is, is paved
with good intentions
and, and the golden staircase.
Mine: rust, grease,
a little ingenuity.
This is just a piece of,
pieces of junk.
An old rim.
Old electrical stuff.
But really simple.
You're just forcing your body
to lay open and stretch.
All of this is stretching out.
The other interesting thing
that I can do,
grab it and come up with it.
Grab it and come up with it.
(clanging)
I wanted to add weight.
Now...
there's a lot you can do,
and I didn't pay this
incredible price to get it done.
The Sue gym is operational.
This isn't gonna fix everything.
This is one part.
The mind, the body, the spirit.
But it's gonna take me from
waiting for the next problem
to hell yeah,
I found a solution.
♪